this is a review expect x boil
exp no hang on the reasons for gone to
want to go
and train to be a pokemon master i mean
hunter
the ash ketchum and gary oak of this
universe leorio
dear leorio i'm not certain i feel it's
justifiable to change your entire life
outlook after catching a boy flying out
to sea
my alternative title for this show by
the way gone and friends or gone with
friends
big fish with crustacean legs the lord
of the lake told us
that we weren't on earth but somewhere
similar somewhere with hunter exams
yes sure he has an unbreakable fishing
rod and he's absurdly strong for a 12
year old and he has hair that
he never touches that seems to maintain
very consistent peaks
it makes him creepy i want to see rage
give me that rage
make a delicious dinner of my words
seeing him dissolve in man's arms and
flowers was
so much more satisfyingly beautiful than
i thought it could be
will our secret not secret ninja turn
out to have more than secret not secret
ninja powers
and tonpa poor outmatched tonpa talking
mustache guy
takes the award for being the most
entertaining person in this episode
i hope you're enjoying my stupid rhymes
because honestly it gives me a sense of
happiness rivalled only by kurapik
no actually no lyorio is not a teenager
why why does he have a briefcase as a
teenager
i'm more hansel and gretel than
goldilocks when it comes to story hisoka
is the insightful creature who sees the
sociopathic
gone as the sociopath i expected
hunter satots looks at them like they
are weird
we can't smell touch or taste what god
is smelling touching or tasting
they both have magical tools the magical
fishing rod and the magical state that
his father who was a hunter at 12 also
young young father let's return to
hisoka for a moment because i love
him isasoka actually gone farther in
disguise don't add too much salt to your
meal but add just a little more than you
have now
warning warning warning thanks
you tried you did it now stop we were
handed them all
along with boobs don't think i missed
the boobs we all saw the boobs there was
a
boob-tastic close-up of the boobs by
leery
old guy there are notably no women
taking the exam
while having the big guy with her whose
only enjoyment was eating let's switch
it over and have the large woman in the
live guy
live guy with boobs two women maybe i
don't know
one who enjoys the aforementioned boobs
and knows how to gently reprimand
someone episode 7
is where it's at y'all yes yes it is
artistically musically dialogically
narratively sonically let's talk about
natero despite being absurdly agile and
quick thinking for an old man he is so
far perhaps the most well-adjusted
normal person we've met overall since we
left meter
we have a dangerous assassin kid i sense
psychological issues y'all
jumping to what i'm going to call the
basketball section of the episode
power is blue maybe he'll develop less
springy frog legs but also fluffy light
bunny rabbits
sometimes those bunny rabbits will be
dark and twisted and may try to eat your
soul but before they do
they'll make you say no if you don't
like it and want your soul back tap that
dislike button
no souls will be refunded since hunter
hunter was written in 1998 it's got a
beautiful relevance now and i'm glad i'm
watching this as an adult with all the
political knowledge
i have now i think the most embarrassing
thing for him at this point and the most
satisfying thing for us watching would
be for him to be
made a hunter so that he can't take the
exam anymore this examiner is also
technically a set dressing at this point
could happen
hello all you'd have to do in theory is
walk up to him and say
phantom troop and he'll punch your
lights out i can kill you without
touching you to play good jazz you need
to know the rules of music before you
deliberately break them
oh leorio waiting to get to the good bit
because he's angry with hisoka but
because he's bored enough to fight the
card-carrying clown
huh lots of c-words today literally a
burning
husk of sadness at the finish line of
horror
leaving you unsmiling and alone like
hisoka at a baseball match
we'll come back to gone and hisoka's
love story in a bit everything's fine
and it'll work out just fine
it's not fine but the similarity between
the two is very clearly shown in their
69.
kilwa wants gone to get to the end of
the exam kilwa and gone will get to the
end of the exam
that's not a test of resolve it's a fact
pin cushion guy
what the actual what is that eating
method
he's like a rabbit or a squirrel it
reminds me of me eating wafers when i
was six after watching my babysitter's
rabbit eat carrots
child realizes at fourth phase that it's
necessary to hunt in order to pass
hunter exam but our little sociopath is
excited by the idea of going up against
his greatest competitor he's crazy
even if someone tried to hit me up
they'd get nothing this can only end in
your demise
gone used the butterflies much the way
he uses his fishing rod it's easy to
imagine his childhood
mocked and left alone to raise himself
he takes solace in building card houses
one day a bigger kid in the schoolyard
creates a minor earthquake leading him
to paper cut the bully unfortunately
that paper cut is across the jugular
resulting in the bully's death but no
one could blame poor pathetic hisoka
right including the knowledge that his
percussionistic teammate is now sleeping
in a hole the art the art his art the
drawing of him
if i didn't know better and i do so i'm
saying it he was aroused we're going to
calm
right down and have the most quiet
episode we've ever had
i'm not going to steal your soul or
mangle your manga or abscond with your
anime
let's just relax and take a quiet nap
for no
what were you thinking it's grand line
waifu punching you in the face with
entertainment like a hisoka to the jaw
if you like business slam your mouse
button onto that like button
too many button if you really like
business say bam while you do it because
that's always satisfying to say
if you don't like business say to put it
simply after all my excitement to start
this review
episode 17 was boring i'm not sure how
they misinterpreted
don't come in as come here straight away
does kurapika have a crush on gone
before you mock me
hear me out yay gone the maraca mover
shh that guy speaking of women
we got to see natero again liam i need
merch to sell get on that
beanies everyone loves beanies put the
oreo in a beanie put hisoka in a cool
beanie put me in a cool beanie
yeah beanies are the best as a
millennial i can totally say that we're
all winners
except that guy with that in mind let's
keep it going with episode 20. goodness
me we're racing through hunters can kill
as they please hunters can
look for things and whether there are
any actual responsibilities about being
a hunter beyond being an elite
something or other creepy guy who dug
his way into the ground only to emerge a
beautiful pinheaded butterfly
seeing kilwa kill bordoro help i don't
know how to pronounce this name
seeing kilwa
kill someone this is unfair because i
know you're gonna edit this in this is
mean illumi can go jump in a hole
frankly
leave my boys alone with your creepy
swirl eyes and your pins of creepy
distortion
where is kilwa today we have happy dogs
happy intelligent dogs do you want to
see a happy intelligent dog
we have them we have them all that and
beanies do we have beanies yet liam
i've seen some of the photos he's pulled
out of the vault some of those photos
deserve the dislike button in my opinion
did i miss something is illumi in need
of
absurd amounts of calcium
no child can carry that many people no
child could carry one people their
children
illumi why speaking of halloumi let's
discuss hisoka's private sexy time
and then there's a tot the man who has
been with them from the beginning the
man who speaks from under a moustache
the man who in fact may not be a man but
instead be a mustache with a static body
softened by a boy with a broken arm next
stop cluck cluck
town chickenville oh
mountain i said it i'm going to call it
the chickenville arc
especially a butler who looks like an
assassin who could probably use the coin
he's throwing to like
shoot people in the head or something
but you have to be able to open
the door what if we're in mika's mind
however and that is scary for a preteen
with a fishing line and no really solid
concept of the use of emotions
i have been threatening to steal your
soul and replace it with a beanie for so
long that maybe we forget i can be happy
and kind and maybe replace your soul
with
insert nice thing here maybe i won't
crawl out from under your bed
with a creepy dog wearing a beanie
hilawa allowing miruki
whipped music anyway as someone
experiencing lactose intolerance i know
i have concerns about the names given to
these characters
like gone we know to just let it happen
who can blame a boy for
stabbing a woman i'm kind of interested
in the idea of maybe gone and kilwa
wearing
uh some chippendale outfits not chip and
dale tails
kilo is free to do what he wants until
he becomes the white tiger assassin lord
his father dreams he will be
frankly i don't know why this photo
keeps turning up but it's the most
horrifying thing i can think of
even more horrifying than this this and
this really what kind of world do we
live in where no one checks on the 10
year old to see if he's even alive at
this point
hisoka's to be believed with his creepy
under the bed face unlike the original
hunters in the phantom trope
troop phantom people what is it about
her that they hired a very short clearly
juvenile person to be a butler at this
manner we found out what hisoka
hisoka they got kill up back boys are
back in town except they're not because
the team
split off immediately leorio gets to go
to cram school and he has his own
cutesy slice of life anime because who
cares about leorio and kurapika when we
can talk about cute little martial arts
boy
then maybe he could go back and finish
the hunter hunter
the hunter hunter exam but what exactly
is the significance of cute fish boy
now look at me while i enhance my energy
and become the one thing you'll bounce
back away from
you scared killa good maybe you should
be i'm glad they have another kid to get
mad at he doesn't
turn up in the brand new opening credits
don't think i missed that oh
i am very percept
his trainer didn't either don't think i
missed that
and can we look at all these food names
please mirki
zushi chickenwing nen is a thing
don't know about ren don't go into
strangers houses
stay in yours instead visit the discord
server hit like
or the dislike button and maybe go here
or here or watch this thing or do this
thing
instead am i getting it right buttons
clickable things this has been the grand
line review
tell me your thoughts on episodes 25 and
26 of hunter hunter
and i'll have more things like this for
you to click
next time